BRET?
FOX NEWS SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST BRIT HUME.
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL A MEMBER OF
THE EDITORIAL BOARD "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" AND TREY GOWDY
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
BRIT, YOU COVERED COLIN POWELL
FOR MANY YEARS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS DAY?
>> WELL, WEIGH WAS A GIANT WHOSE
INFLUENCE SPANNED AT LEAST THREE
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THAT OF RONALD REAGAN, THAT OF
GEORGE H.W. BUSH AND THAT OF
GEORGE W. BUSH.
MY FIRST MEMORIES HIM BRET DATE
BACK TO 1989 EARLY PART OF 1990
WHEN THE U.S. INVADED PANAMA A
CONFLICT MANY WILL NOT REMEMBER
TO TAKE DOWN THE CORRUPT
CRIMINAL DICTATORSHIP OF MANUEL
NOR WEIGHING GO WHOSE
ADMINISTRATION DOWN THERE HAD
DECLARED WAR ON THE UNITED
STATES, BIG MISTAKE.
POWELL CAME TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO BRIEF.
SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE UTILITY OF
AMERICAN MILITARY FORCE WAS VERY
MUCH INVOGUE.
POWELL'S BRIEFINGS WERE
ABSOLUTELY DAZZLING, CONVINCING
AUTHORITATIVE, CRISP, CLEAR,
VERY MUCH LIKE POWELL, THE MAN
HIMSELF.
AND IT REALLY SORT OF PUT TO
REST THE DOUBTS THAT HAD BEGUN
TO GROW.
HE LATER WAS MAJOR ARCHITECT OF
THE GULF WAR WHICH JENNIFER HAD
DESCRIBED WHICH AS THUNDER RUSS
MILITARY SUCCESS FOR WHICH COLIN
POWELL I THINK DESERVES A GREAT
DEAL OF CREDIT.
HE PLANNED IT, HE DEFENDED IT,
HE WAS A BIG PART OF IT.
LATER HE CAME TO CONTROVERSY AS
WE ALL KNOW OVER THE IRAQ WAR
AND HIS SPEECH AT THE U.N.
CLAIMING THAT SADDAM HUSSEIN HAD
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
IT SHOULD BE REMEMBERED IN THAT
REGARD, BRET, WHILE THAT
INTELLIGENCE PROVED TO BE
FAULTY, VIRTUALLY EVERY
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE ON EARTH
HAD REACHED THE SAME CONCLUSION.
SO HE WAS FAR FROM ALONE IN
THAT.
A MAN FOR HIS TIME AND A MAN, I
THINK, WE WILL ALL REMEMBER WITH
ADMIRATION.
>> Bret: THAT COMMENCEMENT
SPEECH WE SAW PART OF IT 1994
FROM GENERAL POWELL.
LET'S TAKE A LITTLE MORE OF IT.
>> AMERICA IS A FAMILY.
THERE MAY BE DIFFERENCES AND
DISPUTES WITHIN THE FAMILY, BUT
WE MUST NOT ALLOW THE FAMILY TO
BE BROKEN INTO WARRING FACTIONS.
FROM THE DIVERSITY OF OUR PEOPLE
LET US DRAW STRENGTH AND NOT SEE
WEAKNESS.
BELIEVE IN AMERICA WITH ALL YOUR
HEART AND SOUL AND WITH ALL OF
YOUR MIND.
YOU ARE ITS INHERITORS AND ITS
FUTURE IS TODAY PLACED IN YOUR
HANDS.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, IS HE
REMEMBERED FOR BREAKING GLASS
CEILINGS, HAROLD BUT THOSE
PRESIDENTS VALUED HIS ADVICE.
RONALD REAGAN, ALL OF THE
PRESIDENTS BRIT JUST MENTIONED
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, YOUR
THOUGHTS TODAY?
>> I THINK, BRET, BRIT SAID IT
VERY WELL.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
HE WAS BIGGER THAN LIFE FOR
THOSE WHO PURSUE A LIFE IN
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC POLICY.
HE WROTE A BOOK HIS LAST BOOK, I
THINK, IT WORKED FOR ME.
LEADERSHIP LESSONS ON LIFE.
AND 12 OR 13 LESSONS.
BUT ALL OF THEM STAND OUT BUT
REALLY THREE STOOD OUT FOR ME.
GET MAD AND THEN GET OVER IT HE
SAID BE KIND, SHARE CREDIT.
IF WE COULD HAVE MORE OF OUR
LEADERS EXEMPLIFY THAT IN
BUSINESS, POLITICS, ACADEMIA,
MEDIA, WE WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
WORLD.
WE WOULD LIVE IN A DIFFERENT
NOW, HE WASN'T PARTISAN BUT IT
WAS PRINCIPLED.
HE WAS KIND BUT HE WAS A QUIET
AND UNDENIABLE FORCE FOR ALL THE
PRESIDENTS AND LEADERS NOT ONLY
AMERICAN PRESIDENTS BUT FOREIGN
LEADERS WHO HE GAVE ADVICE.
TO SAY THOSE WHO SOUGHT HIS
ADVICE IN THE PROCESS.
I WAS REMINDED AS I SAID
EARLIER, BRIT AND I WERE ON
EARLIER, HE SOARED ABOVE THE
POLITICS COLIN POWELL DID.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THERE WAS AMBIGUITY AROUND HIS
POLITICS ALL THE TIME THAT HE
SERVED THE BUSH FAMILY AND THE
REAGAN FAMILY AS PRESIDENT.
WHEN IN MANY WAYS WHAT HE WAS
WAS A PATRIOT MORE THAN
ANYTHING.
I THINK THE GRATITUDE WE OWE HIM
FOR THOSE OF US WHO LOVE
POLITICS THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN IN IT AND THOSE WHO SEEK TO
SERVE IS TO REMEMBER ALL OF HIS
LESSONS.
AND THAT IS FIRST AND FOREMOST,
SERVE AMERICA.
SERVE OUR PEOPLE AND AS I TOLD
THOSE STUDENTS AT HOWARD
UNIVERSITY, DON'T JUST FIND THE
FAULT, FIX IT DON'T CURSE US, WE
ARE AMERICA.
WE ARE BIGGER AND BETTER.
IF WE ARE AT OUR BEST, WE CAN
SOLVE ANY PROBLEM.
HE WILL BE MISSED.
HIS FAMILY, SHOULD KNOW THEY ARE
IN OUR PRAYERS AND THEY SHOULD
KNOW HE MADE AMERICA A BETTER
PLACE.
>> Bret: YEAH.
KIMBERLY?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE THOUGHT
THOUGHT WHEN YOU LOOK AT COLIN
POWELL LEGACY NOT ANY INDIVIDUAL
ACTIONS BUT OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT ONES AND ONE THAT
PEOPLE FORGET IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ROLE HE PLAYED IN THE
WAKE OF VIETNAM IN REBUILDING A
MILITARY THAT HAD BEEN RACKED BY
DISCORD AND DEMORALIZATION.
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT THE LEGACY IS REALLY IN THE
EXAMPLE OF HIS LIFE AND HIS
SERVICE, WHICH IS ROOTED IN THAT
OPPORTUNITY OF AMERICA.
HARD TO FIND SOMEONE CAME FROM
MORE MODEST MEANS.
BORN OF TWO IMMIGRANTSY J MAKE
CAN A AND GREW UP IN HARLEM TO
REACH DIPLOMATIC HEIGHTS.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH HIS
HEIGHTS.
CREDITED AMERICA FOR DO YOU KNOW
THE.
PAID IT BACK SO MANY TIMES OVER
IN TERMS OF HIS SERVICE.
THAT TO ME, IS THE EXAMPLE OF
HIS LIFE IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO REMEMBER.
>> Bret: TREY, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE AS
A PRESIDENT.
HE DEFINITELY FLIRTED WITH IT AS
WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE PIECE.
HIS WIFE REALLY DIDN'T WANT HIM
TO RUN.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IN 196, HE WAS
CLOSE.
I THINK TWO LESSONS.
HOW MUCH THE COUNTRY AND THE
PARTY HAVE CHANGED SINCE 1994.
SINCE HE GAVE THAT COMMENCEMENT
ADDRESS SINCE 1996.
YOU KNOW, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
I WONDER IF THE MESSAGE HE HAD
FOR THE GRADUATES I WONDER IF IT
WOULD EVEN RESONATE ANYMORE.
THE REAL LESSON I TOOK THIS
MORNING.
NOT THE TITLES HE ACQUIRED.
NOT EVEN THE POSITIONS HE HELD.
BUT HOW HE DESCRIBED HIMSELF,
HUSBAND, FATHER, GRANDFATHER.
THAT'S HOW HE WANTS TO BE
REMEMBERED.
AND IF THAT'S HOW WE WANT TO BE
REMEMBERED, THAT'S PROBABLY THE
ORDER IN WHICH WE SHOULD LIVE
LIFE.
I THINK THAT'S A LESSON FOR ALL
OF US.
>> Bret: BRIT, LAST WORD.
HE WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR ALL
THESE DIFFERENT POSITIONS.
BUT HE WAS KIND OF A LARGER THAN
LIFE FIGURE IN WASHINGTON.
>> YES, HE WAS WIDELY ADMIRED.
APPROACHED BY THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND BOONED IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO RUN FOR
DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE BEEN HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM RUN IN THEIR PARTY.
SUCH WAS HIS REPUTATION AND
STANDING BIPARTISAN THE
ADMIRATION.
HE CAME TO SOME GRIEF WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AFTER A WHILE.
HE WAS A DISSENTER BASICALLY ON
THE IRAQ WAR AND SO ON.
AND THEN THERE WAS A MOMENT THAT
I THINK HE WOULD PREFER TO
FORGET AND MANY OF US WOULD AND
THAT WAS DURING THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE FAMOUS
VALERIE PLAME CIA LEAK IN WHICH
IT TURNED OUT THAT HIS TOP AIDE
HAD BEEN THE LEAKER HOW KNOWING
THAT SAT IN A CABINET MEETING
WITH PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH
WHO SAID HE WANTED TO KNOW WHO
IT WAS.
KARL ROVE WAS RELENTLESSLY
PURSUED ON THAT.
ULTIMATELY NOT INDICTED AND
JUSTLY SO.
BUT POWELL KNEW AND SHOULD HAVE
SAID AND HE DIDN'T BUT I WILL
SAY THIS.
KARL ROVE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO SPOKE MOST ADMIRINGLY ABOUT
HIM TODAY WHICH TELLS YOU A LOT
ABOUT KARL AND TELLS YOU A LOT
ABOUT POWELL.
QUITE A MAN